ARC Valley is home to 1,000 inmates half
of whom are violent offenders a few are
juveniles like 17 year old lorenzo
chavez who has just arrived in Juarez
somewhere I heard there's more
beneficial things at y OS for young
offenders but because of the nature of
his crime
Chavez wasn't eligible for y ou s never
thought I'd be here at 17 another adult
prison it's just not a good environment
to be
I have 19 more years to go I kind of try
not to think about it because it does
get depressing if I think about how much
time I got
Java's has been in and out of Correction
since he was 10 as a teen he was dealing
coke and heroin in Denver at 16 he was
convicted of second-degree murder the
result of a drug deal gone bad but this
is the big house here he has to
constantly look over his shoulder you
really got to watch yourself and what
you say around people and what you do it
just makes me stay on my toes and makes
me watch my every move to survive in
prison Chavez will have to find inmates
he can ally himself with for protection
but it's hard to know who he can trust
I sense I'm gonna get beat up here seen
a couple people dragged out in handcuffs
and dogs brought through there's million
ways to get in trouble and more
if he's lucky one of the lifers will
show him how to keep other inmates from
preying on it a lifer like Eric Davis
he's just a kid
lost in a man's world Eric Davis was
given a life sentence for first-degree
murder and armed robbery when he was
just 18
he says predators were waiting to take
advantage of him whether it's tricking
you out of money or pressuring you for
sexual favors probably was in 25 fights
in the first year that I was in prison
there's no one here to protect you
staff won't protect you and other
inmates Tom protects you you have to
take care of yourself
younger inmates who are physically
smaller and more easily intimidated can
have a hard time figuring out how to
survive you're a boy taking care of
yourself in them pod for a bunch of man
is unfathomable because none of the
rules make any sense in here frost the
wrong inmate and the results are fast
and violent it's full-on brutal violence
guys trying to kill other guys in the
purest ways know there's face to face
and it's ugly and it's mean and and
there's no one to stop him Davis says he
has to stay away from young felons like
Chavez who other inmates may victimize
that's trouble for me all the way around
I can't befriend him because then I
would stand between him and the knife
after having served 22 years Davis
thinks adult prison is the wrong place
for Lorenzo Chavez
throwing him in prison to make him a
bigger stronger convict or or a bigger
stronger predator or a victim to be
taken him and turned into a monster
maybe makes no sense